bonsoir bienvenue sur tv fils pour le
7-8 politique une édition consacrée ce
soir aux européennes unique tour de vote
le 25 mai nous avons choisi d'ici là de
vous proposer de débat sur notre antenne
je reçois tout d'abord ce soir bruno
milian bonsoir vous êtes candidat sur la
liste alternative udi modem aux
européennes donc en ile de france
corinne lepage bonsoir candidat tête de
liste europe citoyenne
julie ibra bonsoir à vous vous êtes le
secrétaire départemental du parti
communiste et marquette de basket on
sera donc candidat sur la liste force
vis aux européennes en ile-de-france
donc sur la liste de christine boutin on
va parler avec vous de protection
sociale des entreprises de l'économie
mais tout d'abord l'enjeu principal du
scrutin c'est la participation
l'abstention devrait battre des records
les différents instituts de sondages
parlent de moins de 40 % de votants
allez vous voter et pourquoi voici
quelques-unes de vos réponses dans les
rues de saint quentin en yvelines
bien sûr je vote partout je vois tu as
toutes les sélections de en tant que
femme on a eu du mal à avoir le droit de
vote donc quoi qu'il arrive je vote non
ça m'intéresse pas oui tout à fait vrai
pourquoi je suis quelqu'un qui vote
régulièrement celui qui vote pencherait
plutôt pour mettre des amendes pour
faire avancer les choses parce que sinon
si on veut être pour ça n'avancera
jamais c'est mon devoir et que je dois
voter je suis citoyenne donc c'est tout
à fait normal
oui bien sûr je vote toujours pas ce que
c'est la démocratie avant tout
on participe à la vie qu'on fait on fait
l'auf et l'europe ont fait les démarches
et même s'ils sont pas toujours bons
pour les états il faut quand même
désigné des des gens qui vont
représenter des idées faible
mobilisation pour le scrutin des
européennes sauf visiblement auprès des
gens que nous avons rencontrés à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines je vais donner
la parole à nos invités on va débuter
dans l'ordre alphabétique tout d'abord
avec marc de basquiat donc candidat sur
la liste de christine boutin force vie
vous militez pour la création d'un
revenu de base vous aurez sans doute
l'occasion de vous expliquer tout à
l'heure mais déjà sur l'abstention
comment l'expliquer et puis surtout
comment l'on dit également si vous les
points forts se vit déjà vu vous les
jeux olympiques et c'est un label
indépendant de tout parti politique
c'est l'expression de citoyens qui se
rassemblent autour d'une charte à charge
qu'à lire des films sur le site pour ce
virus et donc c'est vraiment
l'expression de citoyens qui sont
peut-être un peu en attente par rapport
au monde politique et qui sont peut-être
l'exemple de ce qui se voit dans la
population une personne qui se tient
bien le monde politique on ne comprend
pas très bien
peut-être qu'il faut se lever sur nous
mêmes pour vous répondre
ce serait une réponse à l'abstention
peut être permettra d'agrémenter gens
qui ne votent plus parce que le but
poursuivi c'est un peu une exemple
comment expliquer cette abstention
comment inverser la tendance la campagne
très courte juillet bora vous n'êtes pas
directement candidat je rappelle que
vous représentez ce soir le front de
gauche secrétaire dans les yvelines du
parti communiste sur l'abstention
l'abstention ici même je trouvais ya pas
si longtemps que ça au soir du premier
tour des élections municipales je disais
encore une fois que l'abstention
augmenté et je disais attention aux
européennes ça risque une fois de plus
d'être très important et hélas tous les
sondages d'opinion confirme ça va être
effectivement très important pourquoi il
ya deux choses il ya une chose qui est
structurelle c'est que les élections
européennes depuis des années c'est
celle où il ya le plus d'abstention
massivement déjà la dernière fois on
battait un record la fed avant encore
parce que l'europe c'est loin parce que
l'europe ça semble loin et pourtant ça
impacte directement d'une vie de tous
les jours et pourtant
quand on discute avec les gens on est
des militants autour de la table on dise
oui mais c'est loin très sensée au delà
nous ça nous concerne pas et c'est donc
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose d'une chose conjoncturel c'est que
aujourd'hui des gens ne croient plus en
la politique ne croient plus en la
politique je pense notamment un
électorat qui me concerne
particulièrement ce soir si l'électorat
de gauche qui a un sentiment de
déception voire de trahison qu'envoie la
politique du gouvernement depuis depuis
deux ans maintenant quasiment jour pour
jour
et donc il fait dire que la gauche la
droite finalement bas c'est pareil ils
n'ont pas de solution à nos problèmes
est ce ça s'est entraîné un rejet de la
politique et ce rejet de la politique
et bien malheureusement ça génère de
l'abstention ce sera difficile de
renouer le lien avec les politiques
parce que ça va forcément s'inscrire
dans la durée corinne lepage vous êtes
eurodéputée sortante sous l'étiquette
modem que vous avez quitté depuis ancien
ministre également de l'environnement de
95 à 97 candidate à la présidentielle de
2002 votre regard vos solutions
peut-être je dirais que la démarche d'
europe citoyenne c'est une démarche
sur un autre registre que celle de force
vis mais qui ne comporte que des gens de
la société civile je suis la seule à une
palette des gens très engagé qui ont
fait beaucoup de choses dans leur vie
dans tous les domaines que ce soit dans
le monde économique dans le monde
associatif dans le monde du match nul
magistrats toutes sortes de gens qui se
retrouvent sur un projet commun et nous
avons une responsabilité collective
c'est celle de convaincre nos
concitoyens que l'europe c'est leur
affaire
c'est vrai que l'europe ça paraît
quelque chose de loin mais moi qui y ai
travaillé pendant cinq ans je peux vous
dire que à la commission à laquelle
j'appartenais qui était la commission
santé environnement
nous n'avons pas cessé de traiter des
questions de la vie quotidienne des gens
ce soit l'alimentation que ce soit les
médicaments que ce soit les voitures que
ce soit la santé
tout cela c'est la vie quotidienne et
donc notre travail et votre travail
avoue médias ces deux là ce soir pour
bien je vous emmerde ces deux
d'expliquer ce dont on s'occupe
d'expliquer qu'un député européen ça
peut ne rien faire du tout on sait qu'il
y en a et puis ça peut être quelque
chose de très utile parce que cette
défend convenablement que les gens
j'ajouterai qu'à force de dire que
l'abstention va être énorme
on finira elle finira effectivement
parlait tu crois qu'il faut arrêter ce
cercle
vicieux qui consiste à dire aux gens
tout cas ce n'est pas la peine de vous
devez vous déplaciez puisque personne ne
va se déplacer donc tout le monde va
s'abstenir donc fait comme les autres
abstenez-vous eh bien non l'europe ça
vous intéresse vous êtes peut-être pas
content de la manière dont ça se passe
et bien dites le et choisissez
effectivement des listes qui sont en
dehors des circuits politiques
traditionnels qui peuvent vous défendre
convenablement brno milian vice
président du modem dans le département
n'est pas forcément totalement d'accord
imaginez si corinne lepage j'aime
beaucoup de points communs avec corinne
puisque elle a partagé laventure du
modem avec nous et puis qu'elle est
toujours dans le même groupe
parlementaire à l'ald à l'europe avec
nous non pour l'abstention va écouter
oui c'est un état de fait je crois qu il
a raison quand elle dit qu'il faut qu'on
arrête d'en parler il faut que les gens
prennent conscience d'une chose et c'est
vrai ça peut-être si on peut faire un
reproche à l'europe en tout cas c'est
une communication un peu trop flou parce
qu'il ya énormément de choses qui sont
faites au niveau de l'europe
corinne a rappelé sur le niveau
environnemental mais ya pas que ça il ya
eu beaucoup de choses il ya plein
d'autres sujets qu'on était con été
abordés et qui ont été mis en place
dernièrement il ya l'union bancaire qui
a été signé c'est un plus énorme pour
les citoyens puisque ce n'est plus eux
qui vont payer les faillites des banques
les banques vont être obligés de se
rassembler pour soutenir les banques qui
font faillite et c'est plutôt qu'ils
paieront toutes ces choses là
malheureusement on n'entend pas parler
on n'entend parler que d'une chose c'est
que quand il ya une mesure qu'on fait
passer en france et qui est pas
populaire
on dit c'est pas nous c'est l'europe
quand quelque chose est bien on dit
c'est nous mais c'est pas vrai il ya
aucune décision qui est prise que ce
soit en france que ce soit en allemagne
que ce soit n'importe où aucune décision
n'est prise au niveau de l'europe sans
que les gouvernements en place ne l'ait
ratifié il faut bien que les gens
comprennent ça alors qu'attendent les
gens justement vous interrompt pour
qu'ensuite il reste suffisamment de
temps à chacun pourra pour s'exprimer
autour des besoins des attentes des
citoyens européens qui attendent en tout
cas les yvelinois que représente
l'europe pour eux voici quelques
réponses
l'europe c'est une opportunité parce que
j'attends un peu moins de paradis fiscal
et puis un peu plus de croissance
un continent qui regroupe vraiment tout
c'est à dire un mélange de cultures et
fuir un développement une force pour
nous
à une communauté économique avec l'euro
as également l'espace libre ou sarr et
qu'on peut aller en espagne en italie
fin tous les pays européens sans
forcément passer par les douanes externe
de libre échange
j'attends de l'europe c'est qu'elle
propose plus de deux choses une parole
commune déjà une union des pays
j'ai pas la monnaie plus facile alors
qu'attendez-vous de l'union bacon
soutiennent tous les autres les attentes
des yvelinois autour de l'europe
l'avenir de l'europe vous aurez
l'occasion de leur répondre au cours des
prochaines minutes on va commencer par
parler de l'europe sociale le sentiment
fort c'est celui d'une europe qui
abandonne les citoyens avant de vous
passer la parole juste l'infographie sur
le temps de parole qui va s'afficher on
va donc commencer avec vous marque de
baskets puisque ça fait une trentaine de
secondes de retard et cette question
comment protéger les citoyens l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est c'est le méchant qui
plane et qui fait payer plus d'impôts et
qui prend les mauvaises décisions
c'est très dommage qu'on voit que les
politiques ont un discours coup c'est à
dire effectivement comme vous le dit
très justement c'est la faute à
bruxelles c'est la faute à l'europe
c'est la faute à tout ce qu'ils ont ils
à quelque chose qui n'est pas mature
dans notre démocratie c'est bien dommage
donc lorsque nous voulons nous militons
pour l'europe des personnes
disons qu'à être européen ce sont les
personnes sont européennes donc chaque
chacun d'entre nous un twitter et tous
les jeunes pousses des personnes sont
tous européens et donc c'est vraiment ça
avec notre souci et nos campagnes
sociales a effectivement nous voulons
militons pour une europe sociale qui
milite pour les droits sociaux les
personnes et pour cela enfin un des
points clés notre ligue de notre
programme c'est un sujet que le porte
plus particulièrement c'est le partage
de la richesse base est ce que nous
appelons le revenu de base
inconditionnel dans une barre et
conditionnel c'est quoi c'est de dire
mais finalement dans une société
chaque personne a un droit à vivre et ce
droit vivace et ce quelque chose qui
arrive quand on est petit petit bébé on
n'a pas discuté que ce soit il ya pas un
mot
chacun a droit à vivre et ses droits à
vivre eh ben il faut pour les adultes
vous pour les enfants et donc nous
proposons de re faire vraiment une
proposition très concrète d'un une
proposition très qui pèse met en place
dans chacun des pays
nous travaillons avec des partenaires
dans tous les pays européens même dans
d'autres pays
dans mon également pour instaurer ce
débat et mettre en oeuvre ce revenu de
base inconditionnel pour toutes les
personnes
ça c'est un élément clé de notre
dispositif sera revenu de base ça doit
forcément vous satisfaire après chacun
mis les mots qu'il veut et nous on parle
de salaire minimum européen
effectivement à l'instar du dieu unique
en france mais qui doit s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des pays européens
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que dans
certains pays d'europe
l'europe la même entité comment dire que
nous et il ya des gens qui vivent avec
avec rien du tout et ça c'est qu'à tout
des travailleurs et ça c'est quelque
chose d'insupportable voit les
délocalisations ou en roumanie en
bulgarie etc
on voit des travailleurs qui travaillent
pour presque rien quasiment rien alors
qu'en france on pour on est capable en
france d'avoir un salaire minimum il
faut avoir un salaire minimum et
l'échelle européenne l'allemagne a été
capable de mettre en place un salaire
minimum donc il faut le mettre à
l'échelle européenne
il faut mettre la fin des politiques
d'austérité qui appauvrissent
aujourd'hui les peuples c'est aussi ça
un moment on parle les gens disent
beaucoup il faut plus de solidarité faut
que solidarité solidarité ça commence
par arrêter les politiques d'austérité
qui affament les peuples d'europe voit
un peu les conséquences en france mais
il faut aller voir ce qui se passe en
grèce notamment est assez terrible et
donc il faut que l'europe soit vrai
bouclier social pour protéger les
citoyens européens plutôt que leur taper
dessus pour sauver le système bancaire
par exemple quand même plutôt d'accord
avec ce qui était alors je voudrais très
rapidement abordé plusieurs sujets
l'europe sociale est très insuffisante
aujourd'hui nous avons une robe beaucoup
trop libéral qui n'a pas suffisamment
traiter les questions sociales et on
doit largement à la commission barroso
premier point deuxième point je pars pas
je veux te soucies monsieur des salaires
minimums simplement je suis réaliste et
je pense qu'on ne peut pas le faire
aujourd'hui à l'échelle de des 28
c'est franchement pas possible ces
réseaux pour laquelle nous proposons ce
que nous avons appelé coeur d'europe
c'est à dire une locomotive pour
l'europe de partir à une dizaine de pays
de niveaux de vie à peu près comparable
qui pourrait dans les cinq ans qui
viennent
avoir une harmonisation fiscale et
sociale vous le proposer à l'échelle des
je pense que c'est pas réaliste parce
que dans l'es18 vous avez des gens comme
l'estonie comme la pologne vous
n'arriverez jamais avoir un salaire
minimum équivalent en france et en
pologne forcément ce sera différent
il faudra 10 ans 15 ans pour qu'on y
arrive donc nous proposons une
locomotive qui pourrait le tir et enfin
sur le troisième point que la question
du revenu il nous proposons que cela
s'applique aux jeunes je pense que nous
sommes une génération qui se conduit
extrêmement mal avec sa jeunesse alors
que la jeunesse c'est le meilleur
investissement qu'on puisse faire sur
l'avenir tu as raison pour laquelle nous
proposons de commencer avec un revenu
minimum pour les jeunes 18 à 25 ans
qu'ils puissent entrer dans la vie et
mener à bien leur projet quel qu'il soit
est une réponse à ce qui a été disons
même nous on a à peu près on va un peu
tous dans le même sens c'est un constat
qui a été fait c'est que l'europe
jusqu'à maintenant elle a plutôt été
commercial et qu'il est temps de faire
une europe politique sociale il faut une
convergence de la fiscalité on en
reparlera peut-être il faut aussi une
convergence sociale importante parce
qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça ça
provoque du dumping social partout et ça
crée des inégalités insupportables
donc effectivement on n'a pas forcément
les mêmes solutions avec corinne lepage
mais nous on reste sur la zone euro
parce que c'est la monnaie commune à
tout le monde
on peut aussi envisager un pourcentage
du pib pays par pays enfin il ya plein
de solutions qui peuvent être étudiées
et évoquer étudié qui seront étudiées au
parlement européen
c'est important de voter mais il faut
impérativement qu'on aille là dedans
qu'on ne peuvent pas continuer comme ça
avec juste une europe commercial qui
aujourd'hui finalement ne sais pas du
tout occupé des individus il est temps
qu'on redonne au peuple son appartenance
européenne
on parle des peuples mais les
entreprises aussi il faut protéger les
entreprises est ce que l'europe peut
protéger des entreprises qui sont
installés sur des territoires comme en
france on a vu des difficultés encore
récemment avec des entreprises qui sont
rachetés l'autre politique en europe on
peut protéger les entreprises
oui il faut quand même avoir présent à
l'esprit une chose simple nous sommes le
premier pib du monde
nous les européens le premier bien
devant les chinois qui deviennent les
premiers du monde ont dit les premiers
du monde sépare aussi nous sauf qu'on
n'arrive pas à en faire quelque chose
nous sommes le premier bassin de
consommation du monde en termes de
consommation solvable nous avons donc un
réel poids sauf que nous n'avons aucune
politique industrielle
aucune stratégie industrielle commune
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons de faire pour l'industrie ce
qu'on a fait pour l'agriculture une
pique comme on a eu une pac
une politique industrielle commune qui
permettrait en particulier dans le
domaine de l'énergie et du numérique qui
sont aujourd'hui les domaines clés du
21e siècle de mener enfin une stratégie
commune si nous l'avions la question de
je cherche le nom de l'entreprise alstom
ne se poserait pas dans les termes dans
lequel se pose et la constitution d'une
grande entité avec une entreprise
allemande où ça pourrait être une autre
entreprise d'ailleurs aurait été pensés
à l'avancé
nous avons besoin à la fois de
développer massivement nos pme car c'est
elle qui crée de l'emploi local mais
d'avoir deux grands leaders mondiaux
parce que les grands marchés où les
grands marchés du monde
ce sont les leaders aujourd'hui les
gagne et pas les autres parce que vous
êtes en retard sur le temps de parole
sur les entreprises
sauf si vous voulez on peut parler
crûment du fait qu'on va essayer de
faire avancer toute l'europe non je
pense qu'il faut également être que nous
utilisions nous l'europe comme un
benchmark et excusez moi pour ce mot et
que nous regardions ce qui se passe dans
l'entreprise en allemagne en angleterre
ou ailleurs et qu'on dise nous en france
qu'est ce que nous pouvons apprendre à
partir de cela et qu'est ce que nous
pouvons qu est ce que nous devons
modifier dans new règles fonctionnement
de nos entreprises de manière à ce que
la france peut être se mettre un peu
justement dans le quotidien et soit
certains des tringles motive c'est qu'on
a tant parlé de locomotives c'est assez
plaisant on peut dire tiens
numériquement 10 10 10 pc une locomotive
c'est pas le nom qui fait kiffer la
locomotive c'est la dynamique c'est lui
c'est des gens comparent à elle c'est
surtout la dynamique et look si nous
avons vraiment si la france arrive à
revenir dans le temps et dans l'homme
dans une vraie locomotive en soi
d'ailleurs on pourra peut-être faire des
choses aujourd'hui nous avons des
groupes par rapport à ça je pense que la
politique est menée depuis quelques
années n'est pas aussi ce délai mais que
nous voulions est donc là il serait
temps peut-être de nous agiter un peu
pour vous avez vraiment d'un homme ou
cathy locomotive c'est pas dans la
question l'europe peut-elle l'europe
doit c'est pas qu'elle peut sait qu'elle
doit le faire et je vais rebondir sur ce
que disait madame lepage effectivement
la politique industrielle aujourd'hui
c'est le moyen c'est un des moyens mais
à mon sens le moyen pour le plus
important pour sortir de la crise
regardons un département comme les
yvelines on est dans les yvelines qui
est le premier département industriel
d'ile-de-france comme l'industrie
l'industrie automobile l'industrie
aéronautique a perdu en emploi et
surtout en valeur produite
et pourtant c'est cette valeur
8 qui qui construit la croissance dans
un pays et parce que ça a été délocalisé
à droite à gauche etc
aujourd'hui on doit protéger et audio de
protéger on doit comme on dire
réindustrialiser je vais dire le terme
il faut réindustrialiser notre
département il faut réindustrialiser la
france il faut réindustrialiser l'europe
et c'est à ces deux conditions qu'on
sortira de la crise et peint en
inventant des stratagèmes de bricolage
financier à droite à gauche
il faut de la production industrielle
dans le pays et l'europe doit et
l'europe doit avoir une politique
industrielle pour pour permettre ça vous
souhaitez réagir juste pour conclure je
pense que tout le monde est à peu près
d'accord autour de la table après il
faut voir les moyens je pense qu'il y
aura des différences sur les moyens à
adopter mais évidemment qu'il faut une
politique industrielle commune
évidemment qu'il faut créer des géants
de l'énergie européen évidemment qu'il
faut créer des géants de la des
nanotechnologies des recherches et du
développement de demain
il faut qu'on soit présent là dessus on
a quand même des secteurs en france qui
sont numéros un mondiaux on va prendre
le luxe il faut pas non plus qu'on se
flagellent trou on a quand même de
belles entreprises en france il faut
qu'on réussisse à au niveau européen en
alliance avec nos partenaires
aujourd'hui on ne le fait pas et c'est
dommageable je crois que dans la région
de grenoble il ya une société française
très très poussée au niveau des
nanotechnologies qui en concurrence
directe avec une société allemande
c'est ridicule le problème d'alstom ont
marre on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
pas le fait que ce soit racheté par
general electric à la limite qui
m'inquiète general electric est une
belle société mais tout notre savoir
faire tous nos brevets vont partir
ailleurs
pourquoi on les garde pas d'eux dans
l'europe pourquoi les parcs pas à
l'intérieur de l'europe
il faut tout faire tout ce qu'il faut
pour qu'il y ait une alliance avec
siemens
je suis désolé même si effectivement le
patron d'alstom estiment peut-être à
court terme que c'est peut-être moins
bon pour son entreprise
mais pour l'avenir de l'europe france
est très important s'impliquent je suis
d'accord avec vous mais il faut que ça
certes est dans une stratégie
ça veut donc dire des choix énergétiques
communs pour l'instant on est en ciseaux
ce que fait la france est ce que fait
l'allemagne c'est exactement le
contraire
on ne fera jamais une europe de
l'énergie une europe industrielle si on
continue comme ça ce n'est pas le
principal finalement c'est que l'europe
parle d'une seule et même voix aussi ce
serait forcément le plus simple au
milieu de toutes ces questions qu'on a
abordé se pose aussi la question de la
sortie de l'europe certains partis en
parle sortir de l'europe sortir de
l'euro qu'en pensez vous
ensuite les invités en débattrons non je
pense que ce sera la misère après
maintenant qu'on a construit avec
l'europe faut rester avec leur nom jeu
par contre je suis pour les frontières
mais pas quitter l'europe aux propos de
l'euro parce que l'euro c'est très bien
en fait c'est très bien sauf que là mené
un peu trop forte non je pense pas qu'en
france
bah ça fait ça fait des années que c'est
en cours
il ya beaucoup davantage je pense que la
france a toujours fait partie du groupe
je crois parce que doit aussi non
parce qu on a que l'europe pour se
prémunir de tout le reste du monde c'est
pour ça que c'est la france qui va
prendre toutes les décisions europe qui
veut recruter décision par vos réactions
et vos positions à chacun plus
globalement sur l'avenir de l'europe
faut-il au contraire élargir aussi
peut-être l'europe ne passe rien
si vous voulez je pense que l'europe il
faut regarder ça non pas uniquement par
un point de vue économique ou politique
car je dirais un profond de la politique
un qui joue le très noble
l'europe c'est avant tout une
civilisation c'est avant tout une
histoire très ancienne
ça remonte au 4e siècle si tu sois là
nous avons des points communs entre nous
que nous prenons dans différents pays
européens
nous avons beaucoup de choses en commun
beaucoup de choses en commun parfois la
langue un peu d'obstacles mais bon ce
sont des choses qui se met un peu de
piment dans la relation en tout cas ce
qui est important c'est que nous soyons
bien clairs et fiers de notre
civilisation commune
si nous commençons à penser que parce
que nous allons adopter les dépenses et
les idées d'autres nous serons mieux
dans le monde c'est une erreur
vous parlez de vos vraiment
l'association parce que vous ne faut pas
élargir leur offre mais des contrats
d'association et enfin va être honnête
élargir l'europe
moi j'étais réunion du mouvement
européen hier soir on peut plus on est à
28 c'est-à-dire difficilement gérable on
comprend pourquoi les derniers qui sont
entrés son entrée avec ce qui se passe
en ukraine il avait un peu peur que le
grand frère russe via les repêcher un
moment ou un autre qui sont mis un petit
peu sur la protection européenne
mais oui non peut pas on peut plus pour
l'instant il faut stabiliser il faut
construire
voilà on est au milieu du gué il faut
qu'on franchisse le l'autre côté de la
rive et qu'on aille vers l'avant mais
effectivement là on peut plus intégré
deux pays à l'intérieur de l'europe
il faut vraiment qu'on se concentre sur
la vraie construction européenne qui n'a
été que commercial encore une fois primé
sur l'euro pour ceux qui disent que le
sourire aux actes de la vie chère
moi je vais pas être très long sur le
roi je vais vous donner juste deux
chiffres on entend certains économistes
dire finalement si on sort de l'euro ce
pas très grave parce que la dette
publique elle est de droit français
corinne est avocate elle répondre un peu
de sel là dessus mais de droit français
et donc on pourra payer en euros francs
ou en francs et finalement il n'y aura
qu'une dizaine de pourcents de la dette
qu'on sera obligé de payer en dollars ou
en euros déjà un ca c est quand bien
même ce serait vrai on ne parle que de
la dette publique parle pas de la dette
privée de ceux qui ont acheté une maison
de ceux qui ont pris un crédit pour une
voiture une maison et tous qui devons
payer leur crédit en euro et qu'ils vont
voir leurs crédits donc augmenter d'un
bon 20%
donc ça il faut quand même l'avoir en
tête pour ceux qui veulent sortir de
l'euro voilà ce que ça représente et je
vous parle pas des prix de l'inflation
qui va augmenter et ces terrains là je
pense que les gens n'auront plus que
leurs yeux pour pleurer
j'ai les bras on ne sort pas non plus de
leur os du côté du front de gauche et ça
c'est nouveau par rapport à ce qui se
disait avant
vous avez toujours été constant sur
cette question de sortie de l'euro ne
voulait pas rentrer dans l'euro à partir
du moment où on est dans le on est dans
le haut on n'a jamais parlé de sortie de
l'euro est d'ailleurs on avait plutôt
raison mais peu importe
maintenant la question c'est pas sortir
de l'europe à sortir de l'europe
la question n'est plus là c'est l'europe
pour quoi faire et je pense que c'est la
question qui nous est posée là l'europe
pour quoi faire donc nous on parle de
refonder l'europe c'est à dire que en
2005 les français se sont exprimés
majoritairement contre la construction
européenne telle qu'elle se fait
aujourd'hui pour diverses raisons
et pourtant le gouvernement de nicolas
sarkozy a décidé passer en force
le traité de lisbonne par voie
parlementaire alors que les français
l'avait refusée donc aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il ya une différence y compris entre
les politiques qui sont menées et ce que
veulent les français donc on a besoin
un vrai moment démocratique de réflexion
collective en france et en europe pour
réfléchir aux orientations de l'europe
à quoi doit servir ont parlé d'europe
sociale tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est très important dans vos micros
trottoirs j'entendais beaucoup parler de
fraternité de solidarité c'est la
richesse culturelle parce que c'est
aussi ça l'europe et ça c'est important
je parlerai pas moi personnellement de
civilisation peu m'importe mais par
contre la richesse culturelle de ce
qu'apporte chaque pays au pot commun
c'est c'est extrêmement important donc
réfléchissons et donnons-nous le temps
aussi de réfléchir à quelle europe
mouvement au lieu de d'aller à marche
forcée contre la volonté des peuples je
pense aux grecs encore une fois et et à
d'autres et prenons le temps de
réorienter de refonder la construction
européenne autour des besoins des
populations encore il n'a pas sur cette
question de l'europe de l'euro je
demanderai juste d'être très bref pour
que chacun puisse vous avez un peu
d'avancé sur l'élargissement
entièrement d'accord moi j'ai voté
contre de manière systématique parce que
quand vous êtes à table et que vous êtes
il ya plus de place autour de la table
c'est pas la peine d'en inviter d'autres
ça veut pas dire ne pas faire des
contrats d'association ce qu'on a fait
avec l'ukraine et qu'on peut faire
beaucoup d'autres pays ça c'est pour le
ces pour l'élargissement sur l'euro ce
serait une catastrophe de sortir de
l'euro de dire c'est libérer libellés en
droit français mais attendez on rigole
c'est libellées en euros par voie de
conséquence ça resterait en euros alors
ça peut être converti en francs mais si
le franc et déprécier de 30 % par
rapport à leurs e mails vous payerez 30%
de plus de dette
donc tout ça est complètement absurde on
peut critiquer avoir été contrôlé une
réalité c'est l'euro maintenant il faut
vivre avec et rendre l'espace euro-
beaucoup plus démocratique
il n'en demeure pas moins que nous avons
après l'europe de la paix qui toujours
importante
après l'europe économique nous avons
maintenant besoin de construire l'europe
citoyenne dit lord des peuples moi je
dis l'europe citoyenne mais en fait on
parle de la même chose
finalement sur les termes vous n'êtes
pas tous d'accord mais sur le fond vous
voulez fait globalement l'europe qui est
désirable par les gens vous ne
construirait pas l'europe si les peuples
n'en veulent pas ce n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas envisageable et ça ne
marchera pas nous arrivons déjà à la fin
de cette émission va passer à la
conclusion de chacun mais voici déjà
pour rappel les différentes listes qui
participent au scrutin rend l'île de
france qui vont s'afficher rapidement à
l'écran il y a trente et une liste qui
se présente en ile de france je rappelle
que 15 postes sont à prendre dans la
circonscription en ile de france
l'une des huit que compte la france en
tout la france qui enverra 74 députés au
parlement ont parlé tout à l'heure de
l'abstention n'a parlé de l'économie et
ce soir on a parlé de la protection
sociale tout ça finalement en assez peu
de temps on aurait encore forcément
besoin de beaucoup beaucoup de temps
pour parler de l'europe mais je vous
demander à chacun d'eux concluant marque
de bastia on va commencer avec vous vous
êtes en retard sur le temps de parole
vous aurez à peu près une minute pour
les autres ce sera une trentaine de
secondes
il est poursuivi non que c'est un musée
tolèrent ces assemblées les personnes
qui partagent des valeurs communes et
ses valeurs communes sur les personnes
ce sont ces soucis des personnes et
quand nous parlons de re d'europe pour
nous serons l'europe des personnes et
donc il est important que nous soyons
clairs sur la fierté d'appartenance de
chacun dans cette construction et cette
fierté d'appartenance
elle ne se fera pas en reniant son passé
et sa souffrance est un point important
l'europe nous sommes en train d'inventer
ensemble c'est une héros qui est
enracinée qui est enraciné cela que nous
voulons développer
corinne lepage je dirais simplement que
les députés c'est très important que
nous en avons 74 sur 764 qu'il faut bien
réfléchir quand on va voter sur qui on
n'élit pas ce qu'on oublie pas un parti
politique on élit à monsieur une dame
dont on attend qu'il soit député utile
et non pas un député absent ou un député
porte-flingue de lobby voilà et donc je
crois que c'est très important de bien
choisir tout valait 1 précise qu'un tour
pour aller voter est mono 1000 yens oui
je vais un petit peu rejoindre corinne
mais je pense que c'est ce vote cette
année particulièrement important parce
qu'il faut qu'on mette l'europe des
citoyens l'europe des peuples en marche
voter pour des députés qui ont travaillé
déjà sur l'europe et je citerai sylvie
goulard pour ne citer qu'elles
puisqu'elle est partie prenante dans
l'union bancaire qui a été saisi a pas
longtemps ça ce sont des gens qui
travaillent vraiment au quotidien comme
corinne a pu le faire aussi à l'europe
tout le temps ne votez pas pour des
députés fantoche qui vont aller juste
prendre la tirelire voie libre à votre
conclusion
la conclusion c'est que on n'a pas eu
trop le temps d'en parler ce soir c'est
dommage mais qui aujourd'hui à cette
austérité qui s'abat sur les peuples et
qui aujourd'hui la seule liste de gauche
qui propose une politique alternative
crédible à l'austérité c'est là lui la
liste du front de gauche qui est
conduite par patrick le hyaric et qui a
fait un travail d'ailleurs de députés
extraordinaire pendant pendant cinq ans
c'est cette austérité aujourd'hui avait
crevé les peuples je suis désolé est un
peu triviale mais c'est le cas et
aujourd'hui avec la gauche européenne
on est en train de construire un groupe
qui va être le troisième groupe
parlementaire à l'échelle européenne
cinq secondes s'est vite et qui est qui
va à vous êtes un vrai contre-pouvoir
qui va vraiment pouvoir se battre pour
mener des vraies politiques sociales en
france
merci à tous les quatre est revenu ce
soir sur cette demi-heure merci d'avoir
suivi ce débat des européennes rendez
vous le 20 mai avec de nouveaux
candidats n'oubliez pas le replay sur
notre site internet pour voir
l'intégralité de ces échanges bonne
soirée
ceci est une publicité une publicité
vous suggère ce que vous devez faire
mais cette publicité vous demande ce que
nous devons faire exercer votre pouvoir
choisissez qui gouvernera l'europe votée
le 25 mai les élections européennes le
25 mai 2014